there's a movie called blow
that tells the story of george young
boston george
did you know george young that's one way
to ask it the other is what do you think
of the movie blow
i didn't know george young but it was a
wonderful movie
absolutely it captured it it did yes it
did that's the way it should be
so he was a little bit before your time
exactly the same time
exactly the same same he was using
stewardesses to fly the marijuana out of
manhattan beach and i was on the fire
department in redondo beach 10 miles
away
flying it up sending it back somebody
was sending it back he might have been
sending it back
but he didn't have near the excitement
that i did he i was shot down twice
i escaped from five different prisons i
was tortured almost to death in a
mexican prison so he didn't have all
that fun that i had
funding quotes yeah so yours is a heck
of a fun adventure
just to linger on a little bit so uh
johnny depp
plays george and ray liotta plays his
father
and there's this sun-father kind of
scene at the end
i don't know it's it's heartbreaking
like that scene paints a picture of a
life that
could have been had if none of this
wild drug smuggling happened
i don't usually i mean i don't i
almost i really never get like
teary-eyed in a movie but that that got
me
it's almost like confronting at the end
of your life
what your life could have been with your
father the way he calls him georgie
it um like you [ __ ] up georgie
yes i did too i really really did
mario waited for me all those years and
the children raised them without me
visiting me in prisons all over the
world it's unbelievable
just nothing's worth that kind of money
yeah
you